welcome to this video mm-hmm come on
so playing play conop from mrs. Malaysia
yep okay and the names Oh at least
something I know mm-hmm maybe oh he's
playing 92 okay the c6 line is
interesting I recently made this part of
my repertoire playing c6 and d5 g3 yeah
of course he can do that I'm still going
to play d5 hmm yeah that's that's
uncommon really going c5 I wonder I
wonder if she'll play e5 directly
opening up the center before he gets an
F form
but f4 is not not a big issue I mean I
have be 6:05 Bishop a6 no I want to play
b6 here not a six a six what a
ridiculous move I wanted to go b6 okay
maybe I can get it in with the nose of a
temple the point is of course I wanted
to get this in and a6 was just a mouse
slip yeah the bishop should go to a6 and
now I wanted to play Bishop c4 and b5 as
possible mm-hmm yeah let's do that
that's a good a good position for the
fourth edition
okay he's probably planning g-form
later night g3 I wonder if I should go
b5 here and it's not really helping me
in any way maybe just completing
development here is okay
hmm should I take and maybe consider
Bishop a5 takes takes Bishop to a5 it's
not so clear to me what the bishop is
doing otherwise I can play 98 and F 65
but it does not look good to me I can
always play you for himself so let's
take him if he takes with the D pawn I
have 85 this should be good in any case
so this is the recapture no activate at
the Bishop Ian yeah
can I can I use you for him rook to d3
first
also this rugby aid weight rupee aid
would be at quindi at this Knight takes
d5
okay let's let's simplify matters him I
want to use it for at the end and no no
94 or the CAPTCHA I can also take it
it's no problem but that really and then
the night before he very quickly
captured that because of them because of
the fork and now at 5:00 and Knight to
d5 I'm a bit I'm a bit slow on them a
and B foul that is some core cause for
concern like twin B - Queen B seven
something like that
hmm maybe but okay Knight f6 225 is
quite good okay he maybe wants to go
Quincy form okay not not much that I can
do about that
95 here you know that should be okay
I have a rook on a 8 that can maybe
invade on a three masses six pawn is
because that's that's the problem but I
should have enough counter player live
rock b2 maybe rock b2 through p7 hmm
yeah maybe could be could be a problem
okay I need to go for some other counter
play here Queenie a teenage Queen h5
Queen f3 maybe the son can also be a
source of counter play he cannot play
this now because of the check and I
could play Queen f3 just entering them
you know maybe my king is definitely
safe on
but okay is some is well-coordinated so
I'm certainly not better yeah this is
just a question to keep them positioning
in balance with the counterplay I'm not
better than any case c6 is simply I'm a
quite serious weakness okay if I go rook
b8 is ready b6 probably can cover that
as a prophylactic measure so that after
yeah this I didn't expect
he look g3 an idea I have this check
okay I want to go rook f7 rook f6 rook
g3 some I have this check though through
K to check I can go to g1 oops
I have me too okay hmm now he has rook
g3 yeah this was stupid
ah what the heck I just I just failed to
see the the idea of that and maybe I had
no move oh this is a really played badly
okay
black resigns I really should have
enough play with the Queen on in three
years no no question but how do I
actually play it and went here maybe
this was a bit too slow this
prophylactic move
age six King age seven Group G a.m. this
is even better for black need to do this
need to do this mmm-hmm Computers giving
black an advantage even I didn't think
this would be the case
yeah that that's that's him playing out
the smooth I can now double on the
iPhone yeah something like that
here white is fighting for the draw
quite clearly if he allows me to to
enter here my back win is not getting
getting trapped
it's probably about about equal and the
whole thing but then where did I
actually stumble yeah this this and
somewhere around here I already need to
do something age six is far too relaxed
yeah look baby two is strong you know
this is strong here I have no defense
anymore instead of age six I probably
need to to do something something
quicker but the Queen now is in danger
it really is something like this is is
saving the Queen but it's with rupees
six coming it's not a very convenient
structure
I'm not sure maybe it is still okay for
black but I'm a museum not because white
has has a little bit a little bit more
year for can can try to play against
against c6
yeah I can I can enter with the rooks
he's playing out the white moves here
we're just putting some stuff on the
board and now this is the threat black
wins him he must be careful as well
Charlie Jack going for this role
yeah maybe a draw is is the result with
best play I don't I don't know but I am
I simply I overlooked you could be too
mostly here this some later Nielsen
check yeah this is still okay but okay I
guess a fair result ok thanks for
watching